Nathan Tannenbaum with the most accurate
weather now forecast from the 80s now
parking lot where with photographer Tim
zero we're looking at the Raiders
firetruck were part of Raider nation and
we're very excited about our fan day
here and our special announcement the
firetruck purchased a little over four
years ago by the local laborers Union is
toured the entire state getting
everybody fired up for the Raiders
and we're fired up too and so is Mother
Nature so Hector was talking about
Allegiant stadium there's a live look at
the Legion Stadium and it's 97 degrees
at McCarran let's check neighborhood
temperatures we're already at triple
digits in a couple of neighborhoods
everybody else in the 90s and as we look
outside how about Death Valley at 103
degrees now we are going for a near
record high today 106 is the forecast
high the current record for today is 108
now when we look at the satellite and
radar pictures for the western United
States we do have some changes coming
for the weekend but super hot for the
next couple of days let's check in on
your family and friends and we're
talking about severe thunderstorm watch
boxes over Texas you see some much
stronger storms in the Midwest and look
along the east coast that is tropical
storm Bertha it's not going to do as
much damage as it could so we'll keep an
eye on that for you to a Ted florinda
later today now your seven-day forecast
we are talking about near record Heat so
106 the forecast high for today the
record 108 for tomorrow were forecasting
108 and the record is 109 and then for
Friday back to 106 as the forecast and
the record 108 now taking you on into
and through the weekend there will be
some wind coming in on Saturday or
Sunday and that will drop the high
temperatures back a few degrees possibly
into the mid to upper 90s normal high
for this time of year is 94 so enjoy
rater day from the rater nation fire
truck back to you John